we're going back to comic-con the idea
obviously is to kick last year's but we
have make sure that this will actually
work or we're back to the drawing board
so many of the other designs are leaning
toward dragon risk we want to go
different face that's maybe a little
more dragon light I don't mind having
the horns don't go too angry and then
play with tone color yeah this is a good
reason see ya theater feelin okay Bohdan
he sculpted the majority of anything it
was pretty much set when they decided
they wanted to go for a full animatronic
lip-sync mouth some things had to change
because bones original design had t-rex
teeth where the top row is extended it's
it's showing at all times out and
hanging and showing so in order to do
speaking we need lipstick and touch so
we made the palate entirely inside made
some new teeth and gums that are going
to go inside and just adjust the lips to
make it so that they would meet up for
talking we have a design but in reality
that design is the sculpture as a 3d
model so we have we can output it
there's a number of different options as
to how to realize one of these
sculptures so you can sculpt it in clay
you can have it milled out of foam you
can have it grown into the full-sized
piece it's all a balance of time budget
manpower materials costs all of those
mix together to see what the final cost
if I send it over to alchimia they can
mill it out it'll come back rough not
hundred percent which is fine because
then we can sculpt that so that made the
most sense in this case so basically
what we're doing is we've taken the
digital file from legacy and then set it
on this machine this is a five access
CNC router and this is a subtractive
process basically machining the foam
away to get to that final object that
we're looking to do you can say how big
something is but so you actually see on
your equipment and see what you're up
against you get these machines that are
basically sculpt in the rough form
overnight over the weekends / holidays
when he's not even there half the time
it's just his sculpting by itself so
Monday through Thursday so tomorrow at
some time tomorrow the shop should have
that in your hands right I have to head
the head is right here you can have two
or three guys completely refine that
sculpture add detail add realism take
out the eyes a lot of stuff that we
don't have to do here on the computer it
goes off to Alfred we keep working on
other things and when the sculpture
comes in I just throw the team on and so
it's not a team of sculptors for a week
to get that done it's you know two or
three guys for a couple of days
basically goes right here that's the
socket with her yeah yeah it's her from
basically here back so we don't need to
see with her oh yeah those positions
twofer okay cool
the choice that we had in common what
was available to us wouldn't have all of
the detail in there so when it comes
back here we hand over the maquette that
has all of that detail to the
traditional sculptors we're going to
sculpt it right back in to the phone
have reference between photos and this
maquette and bring that detail back into
the foam way Paffett and letting the
machine do it we always try to refer
back to real stuff so bubbles to see
because he talked to this nice fleshy
but she--but would be kind of cool
this alternate schedulers
thank you to figure out where the scale
stopping for the big bushy lip start
yeah all three of these gentlemen have
played very important roles in the
creation of the dinosaurs from the
Jurassic Park movies Chris Swift over
here is known as the Raptor guy in
Jurassic Park one mark Maitri
Stegosaurus from Jurassic to the lost
world and Palma he is he on the gal
amendments the running dinosaurs from
Jurassic Park one it's reminiscent
because actually marks Stegosaurus was
the first large character that we didn't
yellow fall so this is the same
technique we used on the Sega supers for
Jurassic everything will still play so
it's the same technique for use the
dress to to bring back some memories
that can we get McKenzie laying out old
room
the basic sculpture they're big that
gets painted all over once you paint it
did you go back in with some like a
little bee to clean play along that line
and then you sculpt that clean clay and
then you paint it one more time and now
we're off the molding
go to wired.com
the entire giant creature series